hello friends and welcome back to rapid
fire language learning today we're
exploring the question how to get
unstuck or better how to keep improving
your language skills
now i want to premise this by saying
that everyone gets stuck or gets mired
at a certain point in their language
learning path so do not panic focus
instead on three things focus on your
attention on your intention and your
attitude attention means that when you
learn when you sit down and learn make
sure that you focus laser focus on your
activity so that you can notice the
details intention means that when you
sit down
always do it with the intention of
learning don't just watch a video for
the sake of it but sit down and watch it
for the sake of learning intention and
attention mutually reinforce each other
and the third is attitude if you have a
positive attitude then you get out of
your comfort zone you make mistakes you
get feedback integrate the mistakes
integrate the feedback and get better if
you want to know more please check out
my channel over and out